beim sein sollen problem geht es
verkürzt und bildlich ausgedrückt um die
frage ob es eine kluft zwischen sein und
sollen gibt oder ob es eine brücke vom
seien zum sorgen gibt
kurz gesagt also ob sollen auf sein
reduzierbar oder zumindest aus sein
reduzierbaren ist nun sind die begriffe
der reduzierbar kite und der reduzierbar
keita relationen zwischen setzen bzw
satz mengen und das deutet schon darauf
hin dass die im bereich design problems
übliche art zu sprechen und zu
formulieren dass es sich dabei um die
sogenannte inhaltliche redeweise nach
karnap handelt und diese inhaltliche
redeweise muss man nach cannes ab
jedenfalls übersetzen in die formale
redeweise in der es darum geht zu
sprechen über sprachliche entitäten
insbesondere übersetzte das heißt also
wie sie schon aus dem untertitel
vielleicht ihr sehen können dass ich die
sein sollen problematik als eine primär
sprachliche problematik auffassen
denn hermeneutik und reglementierung
beziehen sich auf sprache
aus diesem grund habe ich folgenden
folgende gliederung vorgesehen eine
kurze einleitung sprach logischer art
ein paar vorbemerkungen und dann zwei
teilen der erste teil behandelt die
frage der unterscheidbarkeit zwischen
sein und sollen und das heißt bei mir
zwischen sein setzen und sollen setzen
und im zweiten teil geht es dann um die
beziehung zwischen diesen zwei typen von
sätzen jeweils mit kurzen unterkapitel
dort ist die zeit schon so
fortgeschritten und sie alle haben schon
so viel über sich ergehen lassen dass
ich ihnen nicht zumuten kann das
programm hier vorab zu arbeiten
ich werde also einiges zusammen ziehen
indem ich kurzberichte was ich in dem
jeweiligen teil vorhatte vorzutragen
damit ein wenig kürzer wird
ich beginne also jetzt zunächst mal mit
der kurzen sprach logischen einführung
und zwar wenn wir die inhaltliche
redeweise gemäss karten hat übersetzen
in die formale redeweisen müssen wir
über gehen von der rede über sein und
sollen zur rede über die sätze die etwas
beschreiben das sind die sätze zu den
sätzen die vorschreiben wird was sein
soll
das nennen wir soll setzte kurz gesagt
also wir müssen die rede über sein und
sollen in einem übersetzen über solche
arten von sätzen über ist setzte und
soll setzte nun ist satz und soll satz
wird dabei verwendet als bass pro toto
nicht es kommt nicht darauf an ob
wirklich das wird jetzt ist oder das
wörtchen soll vorkommt wie wir schon im
vortrag von herrn freitag gesehen haben
es kann das warten soll natürlich auch
in eine deskriptive satz vorkommen
sondern es geht um die zwei typen von
setzen bei denen wir entweder etwas
beschreiben deskriptive setze unabhängig
davon ob das wörtchen ist drin vorkommt
oder nicht und den preis kreativen
setzen
das wort press kreativ verwende ich als
zusammenfassende bezeichnung für
evaluation und normative setze ich werde
mich hauptsächlich beschränkten auf
normative sätze wie ist der unterschied
zwischen normativen und wert setzen
bewusst aber man kann die logischen
probleme von der einen seite oder
weniger mühelos auf die andere sagt
übertragen
ich werde mich also im folgenden sehr
stark beschränken auf die normativen
sätze oder kurz die enorm setzte nun als
erstes möchte ich sagen dass wir die
unterscheidung zwischen press kreativen
setzen und deskriptive setzen in der
alltagssprache zwar feststellen können
hermeneutik dass es aber sehr sehr
schwierig ist eine klare unterscheidung
zu treffen falls jetzt kurz zusammen was
ich in dem ersten
daher sagen möchte ich möchte darauf
hinaus kommen dass wir für alltag
sprachen und es gibt ja nicht nur die
deutsche sondern viele andere
alltagssprache keine klare
unterscheidung zwischen den sätzen
depressiv sind bzw
relativ und deren wären deskriptive
setzen treffen können das ist ungemein
mühsam
man muss im detail mit einzelfällen
arbeiten es kommt eine menge psychologie
herein
es kommt soziologie herein bei der pi
oder sprachwissenschaftliche also es
gibt zwar gewisse faustregel man
unterscheiden kann sie kennen vielleicht
die unterscheidung ein besserer indem
man die richtung von realität zur
sprache oder sprache zur realität heran
sie zur unterscheidung aber im großen
und ganzen handelt sich dabei nur um
grobe faustregel so dass mein ergebnis
aus 1a sein wird werden wir in
geregelter weise das heißt also auf
theoretische rationale art und weise
über die frage nach sein und sollen
sprechen wollen dann brauchen wir dazu
eine geregelte sprache und zwar eine
reglementierung sprache etwa im sinne
von klein für die alltagssprache lässt
sich im großen und ganzen hier keine
klare unterscheidung treffen sondern ein
vorschlag ist wir entwickeln eine
reglementierte press krippe sprache da
gehe ich jetzt gleich wieder weg
die wir erarbeiten die wir entwickeln
aus einer deskriptive reglementierten
sprache mit dem vokabular der
elementaren logik wir brauchen dazu
nicht die symbole der formalen logik wir
können das mit alltag sprachlichen
ausdrücken wiedergeben aber es muss eine
implementierte sprache sein in der das
vokabular festgelegt ist und in der
klargestellt wird wie aus dem vokabular
setzte gebildet werden können
wohlgeformte formel in der logik wir
können dann diese reglementierte sprache
entwickeln übersetzen in eine
symbolische sprache indem wir die
wichtigsten ausdrücke abkürzen durch
symbole
dann können wir eins zu eins in die
symbolische sprache übergehen
aber das wesentliche für meinen
vorschlag ist nicht eine symbolsprache
zu entwickeln sondern eine
reglementierte sprache die wir benötigen
wenn wir auf wissenschaftliche art und
weise über das sein sollen problem
sprechen von dem in dieser reduzierten
preis kreativen sprache die also
aufgebaut ist auf einer elementaren
reglementierten sprache ist es
erforderlich mindestens eigenen tracks
kreativen funken einzuführen mindestens
ein
es können auch mehrere seien aber erst
durch die hinzufügung eines press
kreativen ausdrucks wird auf einer aus
einer reinen deskriptive sprache eine
prospektive sprache
dieser zusätzliche ausdruck press
kreativer art für den gibt es gewisse
regelungen ein integrierter name kann
offenbar nicht press kreativsein press
club tief kann nur ein ausdruck sein der
einsatz bilden der funk tourist und satz
bildete funk touren sind ausdrücke mit
deren hilfe man setzen sätze bilden kann
aus anderen ausdrücken und das sind
entweder die prädikate ist gut ist
verboten aus denen ich einen satz bilden
indem ich sie ergänze durch individuell
namen oder allgemein namen und auf der
anderen seite kann es auch einsatz
apparatur sein einsatz operator ist ein
funk tor der aus einem satz durch
hinzufügen oder an wen
auf einen satz einen neuen satz erzeugt
und in diesem fall weil es ein
preiskrieg dieser funktion ist erzeugt
einen restriktiven satz es ist verboten
dass jemand einen anderen oder zum
beispiel oder es ist geboten oder gesund
dass man den nächsten liebt das heißt
wenn wir eine solche perspektive sprache
entwickeln haben wir die gewähr dass wir
in dieser sprache uns präzise
unterhalten können und wir können für
eine solche reglementierte sprache auch
ganz klar verschiedene satz typen
unterscheiden nämlich die hre eine
deskriptive sätze von den preis
kreativen setzen
vielleicht kann ich hier einiges ganz
kurz zusammenfassen
also dass werden das ist das erste also
rein deskriptiv ist ein satz in dem
überhaupt kein preis skript tiefer oder
normativer operator vorkommt im
allgemeinen arbeitet man internorm und
logik mit sax operatoren und nicht mit
prädikaten obwohl beides möglich ist
formal aber der grund warum man satz
operateuren vorzieht also es ist
verboten dass das und das der fall ist
oder es ist erlaubt oder geboten dass
das und als der fall ist das geschieht
aus gründen unter vermeint transparenz
und insbesondere auch aus semantischen
gründen denn sobald ich ein prädikat
verwende
wenn der satz funkt nur mit dem ich
einen dresscode ihr umsatz bilde ein
prädikat ist also ein ausdruck der zur
ergänzung einen individuen allgemein
namen verlangt dann habe ich mit dem
entstanden ansatz gewisse oder logische
verpflichtungen übernommen denn wie sie
wissen kann ich aus jedem solchen satz
durch existenzielle generalisierung eine
existenz satz gewinnen und um dies zu
vermeiden ist es heute üblich dass in
der modal logik und insbesondere auch in
der normen logik für die press kreativen
ausdrucks operatoren verwendet werden
und ich prädikate obwohl formal gesehen
beides möglich ist
nun haben wir also ein beispiel von
einem satz hier ist die symbolische
schreibweise das ist aber nicht relevant
in dem zusammenhang deskriptive
deskriptive einsatz wieder überhaupt
keinen preis kreativen ausdruck enthält
also kein preis gibt in puncto das ist
bei uns ein
palliative relativer funk tor hier habe
ich mich auf die normativen funktion
eingeschränkt potenziellen normativ oder
potenziell press club tief ist einsatz
wenn er mindestens einen press kreativen
funk stoffe enthält also einen
normativen so beratung enthält in der
von mir vorgeschlagenen sprache
aber wenn einsatzpotenzial potenziell
press club tief ist muss er noch nicht
selber press club tief sein
ich habe hier ein beispiel angegeben
hoffentlich schaffe ich das mit dem wo
muss ich drucken ins mittlere sie sehen
hier das abi heißt er glaubt dass
believe ja und das ist ein
neutralisierende funk tories erwähnen
werde und der neutralisiert das geboten
sein oder gesund sein
zu einem disco diesen ausdruck der satz
enthält zwar ein normatives operator das
aber wird neutralisiert durch dem
vorangestellten neutralisierenden funk
tor
der ganze satz ist aber weiterhin
potenziell normativ wären schon
potenzielle normativen er auch nur
diesen teil enthielt ja der teil ist
potenziell relativ bei dem teil haben
wir einen restriktiven funktionär nicht
im bereich eines neutralisierenden
puncto normativ ist nun einsatz wenn
jeder neue operator der ihn im vorkommt
im bereich eines neutralisierenden funk
tor steht neutralisierende funk touren
sind ausdrücke wie jemand glaubt dass
jemand sagt dass dadurch jetzt seit neun
aktive ausdruck neutralisierte herr
neutralisierende funk tor sie sehen hier
dass dieser normative funk tour
neutralisiert wird durch den vorspann
ich hier und der neubau der terror
aktive funk tor das habe forschung
gesehen wird auch neutralisiert also
alle normativen funk touren die hier
vorkommen werden neutralisiert
infolgedessen ist das zwar ein
potenziell normativer auszug aber er ist
pseudo normativ weil alle innovativen
funktionen vorkommen im bereich von
neutralisieren den funk touren stehen
neutralisieren
wenn man als eine satz operator wenn er
aus einem restriktiven satz eine
deskriptive satz macht
wenn er also den pressclub tiefen gehalt
umwandelt in etwas deskriptive dass man
sagt oft auch da kommt der preis
kreative ausdruck nur unwesentlich vor
und deskriptive ist nun einsatz wenn er
entweder rein deskriptiv ist oder pseudo
deskriptive und wir können da noch sagen
das ist ein echt normativer satz
innovative einsatz wenn der potenzielle
normativ ist aber nicht so negativ
also ganz kurz habe dass jetzt mehr
leute damit sie sehen ich kann für die
reglementierte sprache ganz präzise
abgrenzen was ein diskreter satz ist vom
zum unterschied von einem von einem echt
normativen satz werden später dann noch
einführen die kategorie der rhein
normativen setzte die ganz wichtiges im
zusammenhang mit dem sein sollen
probleme
ich möchte alles andere überspringen um
sie nicht zu langweilen
das resümee dieses ersten teils das
jetzt ganz kurz zusammenfassen lautet in
der alltagssprache kann ich nur
pragmatisch herausarbeiten mühsam ob ein
ausdruck wirklich press club tief ist
oder nicht aber es gibt keine einfache
regeln und keine klagen abgrenzungen
wir benötigen daher eine reglementierung
press kreative sprache für die wir dann
präzise unterscheiden können ob etwas
echt pressclub tiefer satz ist ein echt
normativ ersatz ist unter rein
deskriptiv ersatz
ich würde jetzt zum zweiten teil
übergehen und im zweiten teil habe ich
wieder zwei unterteile unterschieden
nämlich bei der beziehung zwischen den
einsätzen in unserer terminologie jetzt
zwischen den reihen des kreativen setzen
und den soll setzen in unserer
technologie den normativen setzen will
ich zwei probleme kurz anschneiden und
zusammenfassen was ich da sagen wollte
nämlich dass nur ein problem und das
problem von jung wenn ich nur und jung
sage meine ich habe damit nicht das was
die leute wirklich gesagt haben wie sie
jetzt wunderbar herausgearbeitet haben
in ihren vorträgen
ich meine das nicht historischen es geht
mir nicht ums historische sondern es
geht mir um das problem dass man dem nur
zu schreibt uns sinnvollerweise
zuschreiben kann ein problem das man aus
nur herausarbeiten kann und das
interessant ist nur selbst ist ja sehr
unklar und und es bedarf der
interpretation der frank jeder hat uns
einmal erzählt dass er nur immer werden
seine schüler frank rede und stevenson
zu ihm gekommen sind und gesagt haben
meinen sie dass und das hat er dann
gesagt nein ich es genau das also er hat
eigentlich sein eigenes problem
entwickelt im gespräch mit seinen
schülern und denen die seine arbeiten
rezipiert haben das was ich hier
vorstelle als ein problem ist also nicht
exotisch sein problem sondern das was
man in der literatur findet und was man
interessanterweise als problem
betrachtet und was sie als problem
erwähnen ist heute schon gesagt werden
dass das bike jugend gar nicht sein
problem ist in wirklichkeit aber was in
der literatur diesen namen gefunden hat
und was ein interessantes problem ist im
zusammenhang der sein sollen frage nur
das problem also zunächst wie sie wissen
handelte sich dabei darum ob gesetze
oder rein normative setzte was rein
normative sätze sind das werde ich
nachher noch erläutern aus sein setzen
also deskriptive setzen die deskriptive
setzte übersetzt werden können oder auf
deskriptive sätze reduziert werden
können
und nur weil er der auffassung er könne
beweisen dass das nicht möglich ist dass
das zu einem widerspruch für die
versuche jetzt die fragestellung nicht
die man bei nur so findet sondern wie
man das problem präzise formulieren kann
herauszuarbeiten es ist die frage ob es
einen normativen grundfunktion gibt
es ist verboten das ist geboten das
opfer als prädikat oder als satz für
satz operateur ausgedrückt ist
gleichgültig er selber ist es ein
evaluation ausdruck aber die probleme
lassen sie eins zu eins von der einen
auf die andere übertragen also ob es
einen normativen grundfunktion gibt und
einen reinen deskriptive satz de sowie
einen reduktions satz bei dem ich den
grund funktioniere gewissermaßen mit
hilfe des deskriptiven ausdrucks also er
ist genau dann der fall wenn de wobei
ich jetzt einmal ein bett in einsatz ja
es ist verboten das pzb wobei dieser
reduktions satz eine formal korrekte und
inhaltlich adäquate definition von m ist
formal korrekt und inhaltlich hat die
partie in der task vision technologie
wie sie wissen
niemand wird bezweifeln dass ein
äquivalent der formal korrekt sein kann
eine formal korrekte definition ist es
spiel zu erstellen die frage um die es
bei mir geht ist ob eine solche
definition auch inhaltlich hat die quad
sein kann und nur hat versucht zu
beweisen dass ist nicht möglich und
viele seiner anhänger glauben bis heute
er hätte diese these ein für alle mal
widerlegt strikt widerlegt ihr versucht
kurz zusammenzufassen
wie sein argument lautet also nur sagte
es gibt keinen solchen reduktions satz
als beispiel nämlich die soziologische
variante des reduktionismus um seinen
beispiel kurz zu erläutern
denn hierdurch heißt verboten genau dann
wenn die gesellschaft diese handlung h
entweder einhellig oder zumindest
mehrheitlich belegt dass roth gedruckte
wort ist der preis kreative funk tor
hier habe ich so ein prädikat verwendet
und das blaue ist der restriktive
ausdruck und jetzt geben wir noch einmal
von diesem satz es heraus die
soziologische variante des naturalismus
die dient nur als annahme eines
indirekten beweises und nur sagt nun die
frage
eine handlung welche die gesellschaft
missbilligt verboten ist ist immer offen
darauf keine krone widerspruch ja oder
nein antworten ja berühmte das argument
der offenen frage nun wenn es also die
soziologische variante des
reduktionismus zutreffen würde dann
könnte ich ja für das wort verboten da
oben das blaue einsetzen
das würde das ergebnis seien die frage
lautet ist eine handlung welche
gesellschaft missbilligt eine handlung
werden die gesellschaft missbilligt und
diese frage gesagt genau dasselbe wie f1
die zu erfragen sie sagen dasselbe
und wenn aber f1 offen ist dann muss
auch f2 offen sein wenn beides offene
fragen sind und das ist ein widerspruch
und daher kann diese reduktionistischen
annahme nicht stimmen das ist grob
gesagt nur das argument der offenen
frage wie heute schon erwähnt wurde
nennt nur selber es ernte die andere
solche reduktionistischen äquivalenz ein
natürliches naturalistische fehler sie
nun würde heute schon erwähnt dass das
natürlich keine fehlschluss ist meistens
übersetzt wird sondern wenn überhaupt
dann eine fehlerhafte definition oder
den definitions fehler
alfred er hat diese argumentation von
nur übersetzt ihnen eine sprache in der
man ohne den begriff der offenen frage
aus kommt der etwas problematisch ist
etwas so unklar ist und er hat ihn
ersetzt durch den begriff der
kontraktion kontraktion ist ein begriff
der allgemein üblich ist allgemein
bekannt ist ein logischer vergriff
definiert und er hat das so formuliert
dass man dann unabhängig von dem problem
des betriebs der offenen frage die
struktur nachvollziehen kann und streng
beweisen kann formal korrekt beweisen
kann dass die annahme ist
und zutreffend ist weil diese annahme zu
einem widerspruch führt und
infolgedessen die annahme nicht
zutreffen kann beim ist es einfach so
dass er statt sagt die frage ist offen
von diesem satz eine handlung habe von
jeher gilt die gesellschaft mit bild sie
ist nicht verboten dass es keine
kontraktion
sonst läuft aber das argument völlig
parallele nichts was nicht gleich
zusammen was ich mitteilen wollte diesen
teil des referats der entscheidende
punkt ist das was ich irgend einem stern
versehen hat
beiden argumenten nämlich beim uhr ist
die voraussetzung wichtig dass diese
frage ist eine handwerkliche
gesellschaft wie es beliebt verboten
dass diese frage offen ist und da ist es
wichtig dass er selber verdient das
nicht sondern er hat nur das morsche
argument klarer dargestellt ja also bei
rs darstellung wäre nach nur der
folgende satz keine kontraktion es gibt
eine handlung von welcher gilde
gesellschaft mit billig und heißt nicht
verboten
wenn wir aber fragen woher wissen weist
er nur das ja dann ist man antworten das
kann er nur durch umfrage in dem er
sprach benutzer fragt nach ihrer meinung
wäre aber die annahmen zu treffen
dann wäre die frage nicht offen und
werde die annahmen zu treffen dann wäre
es einst tatsächlich eine kontraktion
das heißt also nur hat bei seiner
argumentation eine petition prinzip
begangen er hat das vorausgesetzt was
eigentlich beweisen wollte
man könnte mit demselben argument jede
definition zu fall bringen die nicht in
der bevölkerung bei den parkschützern
schon internalisiert worden ist das
heißt das argument beweist zu viel es
ist schon mal zwar korrekt aber es
müssen eine prämisse die nicht
akzeptabel ist
nun obwohl das eine petition prinzip ist
glaube ich dass das argument einen
richtigen kern enthält
der berichtigte kern heißt dass jemand
der einen solch eine solche reduktion
satz erwähnt hat einen naturalistischen
dass der seine sprache die er mühsam
entwickelt hat perspektive sprache sind
taktisch korrekt aufgebaut dass er die
ihre pressclub diesen kraft dass ihr die
produktive kraft entzieht
wozu brauche ich eine prospektive
sprache wenn sie dann keine pressclub
tiefenbach spiel hat das ausgedrückt ich
glaube da nur hatten günstigen punkt
getroffen aber er hat keinen beweis
dafür vorgelegt infolgedessen ist es
wieder störungsfrei möglich einen
reduktionistischen standpunkt
einzunehmen
in der ethik aber auch nichts
wissenschaft im recht
es ist möglich aber muss sich klar sein
dass man sich dann der möglichkeit
begibt echt press club tief zu urteilen
das heißt zu normieren und zu evaluieren
wie das die aufgabe von prospektiven
setzen ist und es gibt natürlich
bereiche wo man sich fragt wer es da
nicht notwendig oder ist es nicht der
fall etwa immer recht ja nach dem
österreichischen recht erhält ein gesetz
geltung wenn drei bedingungen erfüllt
sind wenn ich das richtige im gedächtnis
hat die juristen werden mich korrigieren
beschluss des nationalrates nicht
der bundespräsident muss unterschreiben
dass das korrekt geschehen ist
und dann muss es im bundesgesetzblatt so
war das eben als früher veröffentlicht
seien drei reihen deskriptive
komponenten und wenn die gegeben sind
hat das gesetz geltung also da kann man
sich fragen ist da nicht eine gewisse
reduktion möglich mein standpunkt ist
wenn das auch im juristischen bis zu
einem gewissen grad zu treffen sollte
im ethischen bereich hettich größte
bedenken also im ethischen bereich
bürgerlich eine solche naturalistische
reduktion nicht akzeptieren
jetzt kommen zum letzten punkt nämlich
jungs problem wie würden wir das jüngste
problem nicht da das wissen tatsächlich
formuliert hat sondern das was daraus
gemacht wurde in der literatur und was
er interessante fragestellung wie würde
man dieses problem nämlich ob solche
sätze aus deskriptive setzen und norbert
die besetzung ausdiskutieren setzen
reduziert werden können wir müsste man
das präzise formulieren wie sich die
frage ob es eine satz menge moderne satz
es gibt für die folgende bedingungen
zutreffen die elemente von ems in rain
deskriptive setzte und zwar ist das eine
konsistente menge wenn sie in konsistent
ist es trivial dass ein jeder satz
daraus folgt ein normativer auch selber
muss ein rein normativer sein und nicht
allgemeingültig werden allgemein
gültiger satz aus allen prämissen mengen
folgt und es muss logisch aus erfolgen
ist das ja gibt es einen solchen satz
menge m und einsatz es der diese vier
bedingungen tatsächlich erfüllt und nun
seit langem glauben viele
das ist längst bewiesen es ist
interessant so etwas kann man nur
beweisen wenn man ein streng formales
system hat für preisgibt übersetzte
insbesondere die neuen sätze aber die
norm und logisch die solche systeme
entwickelt hat wurde erst in den
fünfziger jahren entwickelt 19 50 jahren
die semantik die man dazu braucht die
erste brauchbare semantik in den 1960 er
jahren und die ersten beweise dass es
einen solchen satz mittel in solchen
satz nicht gibt in den standardsystemen
der norm und logik ist erst in den ende
der 70er jahre erfolgt also die
zeugnisse spät
ich gebe ihnen kurzen angaben
kommen gleich zurück also fünfzigerjahre
das ist von brig gewesen mögliche litten
semantik das war glück und die beweise
die es da gibt in der 70er jahre stand
von franz kutschera kaliber stuhl man
weiß ja dass vielleicht zum teil auch
kennen
bei dieser analyse vorher ist ganz
wichtig dass dass es ein rein normative
sein muss wenn es nicht ein rein aber
dieser satz ist nur einen neuen ansatz
gibt es die wir alle beispiele nämlich
gemischt press kreative setzte und dann
versuche ich kurz du jetzt erläutert wie
man die haben erläutert was potentiell
war die vier sätze im pseudo normativ
ist jetzt ein echter über die gesetze
und die relativen setzte zeichnen sich
von den bloßen normativen setzen dadurch
aus dass jedes jedes prädikat bzw
jeder satz konstante die darin vorkommt
und jede aus solchen satz konstanten
oder prädikat zusammen dieses die formel
im bereich eines normativen operators
steht fest wo der sp erst dann ist das
ein rein normativer satz und nur für
solche sätze lässt sich beweisen dass es
eine solche möbel in solchen satz nicht
geben kann für das für die diese vier
bedingungen gelten
und auch hier nur noch eine kurze
abschließende bemerkung ich bin
hoffentlich einigermaßen in der zeit
man kann natürlich alternative systeme
der namentlich verwenden alternativ zur
standardsystem in den standard systemen
lassen sich diese thesen nimmt die
negative antwort auf diese frage streng
beweisen
aber es gibt alternative systeme die ich
an reichert ich bin ich etwa eine
standard system der neumond logik
erweitern indem ich solche
neutralisierenden phrasen hinzufüge
handlung sopera touren hinzufüge
politische moral operatoren die
möglichkeiten und
einigkeit dann ist für diese systeme
keineswegs mehr gewährleistet dass sich
die negative antwort auf diese frage die
nicht die reduziertheit diese beweisen
kann warum nicht in ein schulsystem kann
ich zum beispiel sollen können aktion
einführen
alles was geboten ist ist auch möglich
die juristen leben das wie sie wissen
nicht
ultra posten ema obligate so ähnlich
heißt es dort
und es ist naheliegend dass ich ein
solches aktion in einem erweiterten wir
haben uns system einführen
und wenn ich dieses aktion mit meinem
system habe dann gibt es reine
respektive setzte reinen gesetze die auf
einer menge von reinen deskriptiven
setzen reduzierbar sind und jetzt kann
man sich fragen hat seinen witz dass ich
solche alternativen systeme wähle für
mich oder bitte ich auf sicherem grund
wenn ich sie vermeide es nur logische
systeme akzeptieren
in denen ich die nicht der dutt heizte
sie verweisen kann
die juristen offenbar wollen solche
prinzipien um eine gewisse korrektur zu
haben bei ihren gesetzen und es kann
sein dass auch die ethiker auf solche
alternativen logischen systeme
zurückgreifen um zu ermöglichen dass die
ethischen normen kritisierbar werden
nämlich auf diese art und weise gibt es
die möglichkeit für kritik und das ist
ein vorteil für gewisse systeme sodass
ich auch hier sagen würde für standard
systeme ist die nicht der bezirke sind
zwar bereits bei aber das ist ihm
überlassen mit guten gründen ein
alternatives system zu wählen dass sein
sollen schlüsse zulässt und zwar für
zwecke die unter umständen
methodologische interessant sind